Hallo Stefan, wir treffen uns heute wieder vor dem Salon, aber auch vis-à-vis, nicht online, sondern ich bin hier in Frankfurt.
Du hast schon Kultur hinter dir?
Wie man es nimmt. Ich war in dem neuen Magic Mike Film, über den ich aber jetzt noch nicht sprechen darf. Ich habe ein Embargo unterzeichnet, das das erst, glaube ich, am Mittwoch geht, aber in der Filmanalyse werde ich dann am Sonntag loslegen. Ich kann, glaube ich, aber sagen, Stanley Tatum ist sehr gut trainiert. Er ist ja Anfang 40. Da hat wohl die Gage geholfen, noch mal einen zweiten Fitnesstrainer zu engagieren.
Meinst du mit gut vorbildhaft gut oder ansehnlich gut?
Naja, ansehnlich gut. Was heißt vorbildhaft gut? Also das ist ja wahrscheinlich...
Für dich zum Beispiel vorbildhaft für dich.
Gut, da müsste ich vielleicht einige Dinge nicht mehr machen. Zum Beispiel so Podcasts mit dir aufnehmen und sagen, ich habe leider keine Zeit, ich muss ja ins Studio.
Es ist direkt hier um die Ecke.
Ich vermute, das ist nicht so mit 60 Minuten getan, oder?
Wenn du es jeden Tag machst, reiche ich ja auch eine halbe Stunde.